US President Donald Trump says China
could have stopped the kovat 19 outbreak
quickly and prevented it from spreading
across the world he said the US was
carrying out serious investigations and
suggested Washington could seek
reparations for economic damage done by
the virus his briefing also focused on
moves to reopen businesses and schools
an issue that's put the federal
government at odds with state governors
and ended in mixed messages for the
public in the United States governors
are making very different decisions on
whether to ease the lockdown very much
you think a lot of governor's get out
and they want to open it up many are
thinking about their school system not a
long way to go in the school system
right now for this season for this year
but I think you'll see a lot of schools
open up even if it's for a very short
period of time I think it would be a
good thing in Georgia restaurants nail
salons and even cinemas are already
opening up for business despite 25,000
reported cases of covert 19 in the
southern state it's not a decision we
take lightly but we do know that the
governor has allowed it here in Georgia
and we're looking to his leadership as
an indication of when when it's
appropriate for us to open while in
California and Texas hundreds of people
are visiting beaches very little is open
for business in the deprived city of
Baltimore Maryland
which has reported almost 20,000 cases
of the virus
the future current conditions right now
so I think they needed to make clothes
for now the lockdown can't continue
forever but each state will have to make
its own decisions about how and when to
end it
well the briefing you saw a president
Trump giving in that report was his
first following a storm of criticism
over his remarks about injecting
disinfectant to cure coronavirus I asked
our Washington correspondent Stefon
Simmons whether the president has
managed to shake off that controversy
well I think no he didn't he's doing his
best to ignore it
he clearly caused it and as you remember
he tried to pedal back a day after
claiming that he just made sarcastic
comments and that it was more or less
jokingly what he had said that people
should consider ingesting or injecting
disinfectants inside their bodies to
clean their lungs or ultraviolet light
of course the experts came out to say
well please don't do this if the
companies who produce this came out to
say please don't do this because it will
kill you you cannot ingest anything
disinfectant Clorox the messed us all
ISIL or whatever the products are and
now what is the president doing he's
ignoring any other and further questions
he said today he will not be held
responsible for a upsurge in calls to
the poison centers here in the United
States over the weekend and the days
before people calling in asking if they
should take the president serious and
ingest disinfectants he says he's not
responsible for this and again as I said
he claims now they have made sarcastic
comments only well moving on to New
Zealand where nearly half a million
people have gone back to work as the
government eases the national lock down
some aspects of daily life are getting
back to normal
hospitality businesses including coffee
shops reopened for takeaways
construction and work on major
infrastructure projects is also resuming
Prime Minister Jacinda are down thank
New Zealanders for the resilience during
the shutdown but she warned that the
fight against the virus is not over yet
it is an ongoing battle there is not one
point in time that this mission ends now
yes we have done that in lockdown the
goal now is to keep up that work so
we're now in the next phase of the
battle and we are not done around 75
percent of the economy is operating with
key sectors like building and
construction forestry manufacturing and
contactless retail starting back up
importantly major infrastructure
projects start up again today now let's
catch up on some of the other stories
making headlines around the world today
the Australian city of Sydney has
reopened its famous Bondi Beach to
surfers and swimmers golden sands were
closed last month after thousands of
people ignored social distancing rules
residents are now allowed back in the
water but walking and sunbathing remain
banned the British public will hold a
minute's silence today to pay tribute to
frontline workers who've died after
contracting kovat 19 the government has
announced it will make a 60 thousand
pound compensation payment that's all 70
thousand euros to families of health
workers and social care staff who were
died fighting the outbreak after years
of underfunding and now a severe lack of
personal protective equipment the
pandemic has laid bare the crisis within
the UK's national health system a nonce
leaf gown that protects him from
coronavirus dr. Aziz muna almost feels
guilty every time he puts one on he's an
emergency doctor so he does have access
to Pastner protective equipment or PPE
but supplies across the UK are very
limited there simply aren't enough gowns
for every doctor but we have to wear it
you know we are in three quarters of all
UK doctors say they don't have access to
protective clothing
Rises and masks are also in short supply
some doctors are having to buy their own
FFP three masks from DIY stores and from
building merchants and we're also having
to do things like make their own aprons
out of rubbish bin bags to try and
protect their clothing whilst they're
doing these high-risk procedures over
100 medical staff doctors as well as
nurses have already died from the virus
on social media videos like this are
being shared hospital workers paying
their last respects to a colleague even
before the crisis the UK was short of
over 40,000 nurses staff are now under
enormous pressure even very experienced
nurses have been pushed to the edge and
we have a lot of newly qualified staff
who've only been in the job six months
or one year and they've really been
pushed pushed - - to breaking point we
are already underfunded we need more
doctors and nurses to work in the NHS
even in normal times so at the moment we
are above and beyond what we ever
thought that we could be in terms of
working and we're trying our best but we
do need more staff and we need more
equipment and that is a result of
underfunding over the last decade and
patients are suffering - hospitals are
having to ration supplies like oxygen or
dialysis fluid for patients with kidney
failure doctor moon of described
situations where all the patients that
might have benefited from intensive care
have been denied treatment whereas a few
months ago people over 65 would have
perhaps considered incubating a
ventilating them but now these criteria
are so stringent so the trusts are very
reluctant to intubate people above the
only 55 I a few patients which I deemed
appropriate the intensive care unit but
the ICU people rejected a lot it wait
for rationing Britain's National Health
Service is facing its biggest emergency
since its founding
and DWS Bearcat mass who filed that
report joins us now from London
Birgit the UK is a rich country that's
been mobilizing resources to deal with
this pandemic for months yet its health
system is having real trouble coping why
well when you look at it from the
outside the UK health system comes
across as not being very resilient it's
not being designed to cope with a
pandemic like this you could almost say
it's almost run was almost before the
pandemic running at full capacity so
this huge surge and patients hospitals
have just really had to struggle you
have almost no other any other elective
surgery or even things like Hansa care
at the moment everything has been on
hold everything has stopped just in
order to deal with this crisis and
cancer charities for example a warning
that thousands of cancers are going
undetected because patients are
reluctant to go to GPS but also there
are no referrals to specialists and and
no surgeries so it will present a huge
problem also further down the line when
slowly all these normal services are
being resumed and yes critics say that
this is due to severe underfunding
particularly in the last decade where
the country has seen a lot of austerity
as a result of the financial crisis at
noon Britain is to hold a minute silence
to commemorate key workers who have died
from Cova at 19 tell us more about that
well yes like in many other countries
key workers particularly hospital staff
doctors nurses they're being seen as
heroes across the UK you see in many
windows there are little rainbows that
symbolize the NHS and symbolize the
support that families and the gratitude
that they have for NHS workers now this
is a minute of silence
- well have the whole country come
together and commemorate these people
who have sacrificed their life while
they were helping others to survive
we've also seen on the back of this the
government announcing a new scheme a
compensation scheme so for four key NHS
workers who have died or will be dying
in the future there will be a financial
compensation so this is also an official
mark of the gratitude that the
government is showing to everybody who's
on the frontline against the virus well
speaking of the government yesterday we
saw Prime Minister Boris Johnson back in
public back at work for the first time
since he contracted the corona virus how
important is his return for the
country's battle against the pandemic
well there was a sense of void at the
helm of the government at this really
key moment in the country's history
really because of course there were only
ministers giving daily updates but there
was a sense that maybe the really big
decisions weren't being taken just
because the Prime Minister wasn't there
and wasn't there to basically lead the
country so we have seen now that Boris
Johnson has come in for example this
official support for the care workers
that we have just talked about but also
what's being expected of him is really
what comes next how is he going to
believe the country out of this crisis
we see in many other countries across
the world are slowly opening up the very
strict lockdown the UK is not one of
those people are really pressing the
prime minister to be transparent and to
talk about what strategy is the UK going
to have and what's the thinking what's
the government thinking of the head of
the government really behind when is the
country opening up and we can expect
many more people pressing the prime
minister just to be more open in the new
future bigger thank you very much that
was CW's big at mass in London let's get
a roundup now of some of the latest
developments in the pandemic the number
of confirmed Cova die
eighteen cases worldwide has passed
three million that's courting to the
John Hopkins University database new
figures show that transmissions in
Germany have ticked higher the
reproduction rate is now back at one
meaning those infected with the virus
pass it to one other person starting May
1st Austria will allow gatherings of up
to 10 people as the country eases
restrictions and Spain and France will
also outline plans today on how to lift
their six-week walk downs this week saw
Spain's children leave the confinement
of their homes for the first time in six
weeks the decision followed heated
public debate about Spain's very strict
curfew there had been growing calls to
loosen the restrictions for youngsters
with experts warning of the
psychological impact of keeping children
indoors DWS young Philip Schultz went to
meet one family as they left lockdown
Ava Ava and javi have waited for 43 days
for this exact moment they are finally
allowed to leave their apartment again
accompanied by their mother of course
they say it's a great feeling but a
little unusual - you see a lot of kids
hardly any adults on the street and
there aren't any cars the constraints
imposed on children were some of the
strictest in Europe they were not
allowed outside not even for a few
minutes this gives them all the more
reasons to be excited about what's
finally possible again my friend lives
really close maybe I can at least see
her from a distance but only from a
distance and tomorrow we all go
rollerskating YouTube today's
destination grandma and grandpa but very
strict rules apply while getting there
cycling and running is allowed playing
with other kids is not their
grandparents house is within the
permitted 1 kilometer radius but
visiting them is not the same as it used
to be grandpa is not allowed to hug
olive
this is something everybody has to get
used to several days of confusion
preceded the Spanish government's
decision to allow children to go outside
for walks again the original plan was
that they would only be allowed to
accompany their parents to the
supermarket but eventually the public
pressure became too strong more and more
parents insisted that after six weeks
without any fresh air the limit for
children had been reached many experts
are glad about that government's change
of heart including psychiatrist Diego
Figueroa he was one of the many who
advocated to loosen the restrictions for
children but even if the measures are
gradually reduced new problems might
arise children that have been spending
most of their time with their parents
might have a hard time adjusting to
school or other groups outside their
families again this might cause serious
phobias or even result in kids refusing
to leave the house Ava Ava and javi
enjoy that time outside despite the new
strange circumstances the allotted 60
minutes pass away too quickly the three
of them are already making plans for
tomorrow when they can spend their next
hour outside and maybe Alba will be able
to see her girlfriend even if it's only
from a distance for more on this let's
talk to Hank Herod Rudkin she's a child
clinical psychologist at the University
of Southampton in England thanks for
joining us what are the main
psychological challenges that children
face in this pandemic I think this
there's many actually I think that the
lack of social contact with people
outside their family is a big one but I
think also the intensity of living
inside that family unit so squabbles
with siblings Rottier parents I think it
can all help to create quite a bit of
turmoil for children especially younger
children who find it difficult to
understand what is going on
but for teenagers in particular they're
a real worry actually because they rely
so heavily on social contact with peers
every single day to help them feel good
about themselves so they've really
missed out on that as well so there's a
lot of psychological and impacts really
but one thing that I have found is that
the young people that I was working with
before this all happened and I was
working with them around anxiety they're
enjoy in a temporary relief from their
anxieties because they're now living in
a bubble and the things that used to
make them feel really anxious and such
as going to school or seeing other
people has actually reduced so for some
people it hasn't been all bad
okay so social distancing is
particularly tough for young people but
what about the general psychological
environment to living in a situation
where there's a killer virus on the
loose and people are dying in their
thousands all around them I mean this
must be a particular burden for them i I
think that threat is is enormous but
from my experience I think it's more the
adults who've really processed that
threat very young children it's just too
big for them to take on they can't
really understand the enormity of it so
we have to bring it down to the day to
day wash your hands
don't go near Pete other people for
teenagers I think they felt quite a bit
of existential angst around it but
because it's not hitting teenagers as
much as other age groups I think they're
feeling pretty protected from it in fact
so the biggest threat is changes to
families in terms of grandparents and
elderly relatives and vulnerable
relatives so a lot of young people are
dealing with that threat okay actually
and and more what they're experiencing
difficulties with this is a day-to-day
I'm not being able to see their friends
what advice would you give to parents as
a child psychologist to help them
support their children in coping with
this crisis it's a really difficult time
and parents are going to be putting a
lot of expectations on themselves and
actually it's the toughest job in the
world at the best of times so right now
is gonna be very very tough so as a
parent just set yourself small goals
what is it that you would like to do to
make sure that that day's gone okay a
couple of things that you want to get
done
go very easy on yourself as a parent but
in terms of your child don't worry about
them having to you know be incredibly
educated during this time you just need
to tread water with the learning a lot
of parents are very anxious about screen
time and how much time their children
especially teenagers are spending gaming
during the day and again it's just about
having to take just take a step back as
a parent and think what is it that I
need to do right now I need to keep my
child well and safe and healthy and
these just involve little steps they
don't need to involve any big changes
thank you so much that was an herit
Rudkin a she's a child psychologist at
the University of Southampton thanks for
talking with us well the coronavirus
lockdown has sometimes meant loneliness
especially for the elderly here among
the most vulnerable in this pandemic
they're cut off from friends and
relatives they haven't seen for months
but one enterprising belgian businessman
has come up with an idea that's taken
some of the distance out of social
distancing Clementine has been waiting
for this moment for almost two months
her husband is in this Brussels care
home the last time she saw him was in
early March now they're reunited for a
few precious minutes this is great isn't
it it's great I think I'll have to stay
here the idea of using cranes to hold
people closer together was a brainchild
of Tristan fundin Bosch he's a manager
of the company that rents out the
platforms for window cleaning and fruit
picking
exactly month I saw somebody waving at
his mother two or three floors up and I
thought given that we have a serious
fall in business we can lift that man up
to the window with our machines and
that's what we did
84 year old Clementine says that the
crane ride has given her at least a
semblance of intimacy with her loved one
I am very happy that I could speak to
him that closely it's great I really
appreciate this initiative now
clementines back down on solid ground
and her husband's still in lockdown even
so just a few minutes with him have made
a huge difference
[Applause]